[Musique]
voici les fonds bâtissemo de la ville
libre de Tours sculptés dans la pierre
une cité antique datée du quatrième
siècle promu au rang de capital romaine
habitait à l'époque par les Turons ces
vestiges se trouvent sous terre à la
plomb de l'ancien palais des archevêques
devenu musée des Beaux-Arts un
souterrain énigmatique dont on ne
connaît pas avec certitude l'utilité
pour les chanoines qu'ils l'ont creusé
on n'a pas vraiment d'informations sur
l'utilité de ce souterrain pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'a pas été comblé mais on
suppose que ça servait de cave et pour
les chats noirs et qu'est-ce qu'on
stockait à l'époque avec les chanoine la
nourriture mais surtout une boisson qui
était très utilisée pour le charisme
le vin rouge
à l'époque chanoine et évêque appréciait
le lieu pour sa proximité avec la
cathédrale la ville antique était sainte
de remparts et de 16 tours rondes une
seule est encore visible à l'extérieur
du musée
s'enfoncer dans les entrailles de
l'édifice revient à faire un bon dans
l'histoire de la ville métropole un
souterrain insoupçonnable lorsqu'on
visite le musée
j'ai tout rangé elle depuis 40 ans et je
savais pas du tout le temps que j'ai
l'habitude de venir au musée là et je
savais pas du tout qu'il y avait un
souterrain sous le musée des Beaux-Arts
voilà c'est vraiment très intéressant
très intéressant passionnant on est là
depuis des années et on découvre des
choses pour la première fois c'est c'est
super sympa le lieu regorge de toute une
symbolique utilisée dans ses
inscriptions gravées qui prennent la
forme de blason tour en jeu des cuissons
de tête de diable ou encore d'animaux
certaines restent indéchiffrables il y a
pas eu d'études approfondie ici mais on
sait notamment que le petit oiseau date
du Moyen-Âge donc ça veut dire que cette
muraille a été constamment réutilisée
pour resservir à d'autres bâtiments à
d'autres constructions
les souterrains du musée des Beaux-Arts
de Tours se visitent chaque troisième
dimanche en matinée ou en après-midi la
réservation est nécessaire le groupe est
limité à 15 visiteurs